[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est
un vrai plaisir pour moi d'être avec
vous aujourd'hui alors ce talk que je
vais vous proposer il s'adresse à vous
ici dans cette salle mais aussi à vous
avoue là derrière vos écrans qui est
peut-être actuellement au travail en
train de vous ennuyer profondément et
qui préférait passer votre après midi à
de regarder des vidéos sur youtube alors
que je vais commencer par vous adresser
une question à tous est-ce qu'il y en a
parmi vous qui ont l'impression que leur
job est devenu un peu trop plan plan
est-ce qu'il y en a parmi vous qui ont
l'impression d'être englués dans un
métro boulot dodo ou votre job est
devenu vraiment une routine
est-ce que vous vous sentez parfois
emprisonnés dans un job qui ne vous
convient plus vraiment est-ce que vous
rentrez parfois du travail en étant
déçus de vos journées est ce que vous
êtes parfois avec un sentiment
d'inutilité ou de frustration
est ce que vous vous ennuyez dans votre
job
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
vous pourriez en faire beaucoup plus en
résumé est ce que vous faites partie de
ceux qui ont perdu la flamme pour leur
job
une récente enquête ipsos a révélé que
54 % des français sont démotivés au
travail faites vous partie de ceux là et
si oui pourquoi votre situation
n'est-elle pas différente
est-ce que parfois dans un coin reculé
de votre tête vous avez l'impression que
vous ne pouvez rien y faire que les
cartes ne sont pas dans votre dans vos
mains et que vous devez faire ce qu'on
vous demande un point c'est tout si
c'est ce que vous pensez écoutez ceci
les employés le plus heureux contrat au
travail sont ceux qui modèlent leur job
pour qui leur convienne mieux ce sont
ceux qui
dapd leur job alors puisqu'il semble
possible de raviver la flamme pour votre
job de remettre un peu de miraculeux
dans ce qui est peut-être devenu trop
commun pour vous pourquoi ne pas le
faire et comment eh bien je vais vous
proposer aujourd'hui quelques pistes de
réflexion pour savoir comment faire ce
que certains chercheurs ont appelé du
job crafting alors le job crafting c'est
quoi et bien c'est faire son job faire
ce pour quoi on est payé mais en le
modélisant en le modifiant pour qu'ils
nous conviennent mieux c'est par exemple
ajouter ou supprimer certaines tâches
s'échanger certaine manière de faire
certains process c'est modifier votre
contexte de travail ou par exemple
changer le sens que vous donnez à votre
job under crafter sait qui c'est par
exemple un informaticien qui crée une
capsule vidéo spontanément pour informer
ses collègues d'une nouvelle procédure
c'est un manager qui organise des
réunions petit déjeuner pour joindre
l'utile à l'agréable
c'est aussi à un enseignant qui
réorganise toute sa classe pour la
rendre plus fonctionnelle et enfin c'est
par exemple un éboueur qui a le
sentiment de contribuer au sauvetage de
la planète en participant au tri
sélectif raviver la flamme pour son job
quel beau programme en faisant du jack
rafting vous pouvez augmenter votre
satisfaction au travail en étant plus
satisfait vous allez être plus engagés
et parce que vous serez plus engagé vous
pourriez devenir plus performants
intéressant n'est-ce pas vous allez me
demander
c'est bien beau tout ça mais comment
faire avant toute intervention il ya une
étape préliminaire celle du diagnostic
ce soir quand vous rentrez chez vous
prenez une feuille de papier ou un
tableur excel pour les plus
informaticiens parmi vous ai indiqué zee
rapportés ici toutes les activités que
vous faites sur une base quotidienne
une hebdomadaire et mensuelle aller plus
loin que votre description de fonction
je voudrais vraiment que sur cette fiche
figurent toutes les petites activités
qui remplissent vos journées imaginons
que je sois coach et formatrice interne
je pourrais dressé une liste comme celle
ci ensuite pour chacune de ses activités
je voudrais que vous puissiez la noter
sur une échelle de 1 à 10 dans quelle
mesure est ce que cette activité est
source pour moi deux sens sur une
échelle de 1 à 10 dans quelle mesure
respecter cette activité est source de
plaisir pour moi et dans quelle mesure
est ce que cette activité mobilisent
mais à tous et mes compétences
voilà on va prendre un exemple effectuer
le suivi de la comptabilité mon
comptable c'est très bien pour moi cette
source de très peu de sens de plaisir et
c'est absolument hors de mon champ de
compétence si vous aussi vous vous
rendez compte que vous avez des
activités qui sont en dehors de ces
trois cercles qui ne sont pour vous ni
source de sens ni le plaisir et qui ne
mobilise pas vos atouts posez vous la
question suivante est ce que ça fait
partie de votre description de fonction
est ce qu'on vous demande de le faire et
si vous le faites pourquoi est ce que
vous le faites si vous vous rendez
compte que vous vous effectuer certaines
tâches pour de mauvaises raisons
n'ayez aucun scrupule et éliminer les
purement et simplement de votre agenda
pour cet âge de -2 vous également si
vous pouvez pas éventuellement les
délégués et si toute l'équipe
toute mon équipe et moi on faisait cet
exercice ensemble est-ce qu'on se
rendrait par exemple compte que
certaines activités qui sont en dehors
de mes trois cercles sont à l'intérieur
des cercles de quelqu'un d'autre
est ce qu'il y a dans mon équipe un féru
des chiffres qui seraient contents de
récupérer ces tâches de comptabilité
et enfin si c'est à vous qu'incombe
cette responsabilité demandez vous si
vous pouvez pas dans une certaine mesure
l'adapter pour rendre cette activité
moins lourdes ou plus agréable est-ce
qu'il n'existe pas par exemple un
programme comptable qui vous permettent
de faire cette tâche plus facilement est
ce que vous pouvez faire la comptabilité
avec un collègue sympa dans un endroit
agréable pour rendre cette tâche un peu
plus légère
ensuite intéressez-vous aux tâches qui
sont sources de peu de sens pour vous
dans mon cas organisé une soirée pour
fêter les performances de l'équipe de
commerciaux ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens
pourquoi parce que je suis pas super
porter chiffres et performance
financière
si vous aussi on vous demande effectuer
certaines tâches qui sont pas forcément
source de sens pour vous demandez vous
si vous ne pouvez pas ré interpréter
cette tâche lui donner une nouvelle
valeur une nouvelle interprétation dans
mon café thé des performances
financières ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens
par contre si on a vendu beaucoup de
formations ça veut dire qu'on a formé
pas mal d'employés ça veut dire qu'on
les a aidés à se développer dans leur
vie professionnelle
et ça ça a du sens pour moi
demandez-vous ensuite quelle quel est le
sens noble de vos actions au travail
quel est votre super pouvoirs au travail
à qui est-ce que vous rendez service
dans quels projets plus grand est ce que
vous vous inscrivez rappelez vous de ce
sens là ensuite une excellente manière
de rajouter du sens dans votre travail
c'est d'identifier quelles sont vos
valeurs à vous en tant qu'individu et
essayer d'injecter ces valeurs dans
votre entreprise
si pour vous la collaboration quelque
chose de très important et que vous avez
l'impression que chacun travaille un peu
dans son coin
pourquoi ne pas organiser des réunions
de manière un peu plus fréquentes autour
d'une tasse de café par exemple pourquoi
ne pas proposer de mettre sur pied un
programme de parrainage des nouveaux
arrivés dans l'entreprise si c'est
plutôt l'écologie qui vous branche
pourquoi ne pas proposer un système de
covoiturage pour arriver sur le lieu
veille intéressez-vous ensuite aux
activités qui sont sources de peu de
plaisir compléter le rapport annuel
ok j'en comprends le sens ça mobilise
mes forces mais à tous mais par contre
ça m'agace profondément
si vous aussi il ya des activités qui
vous procure peu de plaisir
essayez de comprendre quel est le
message caché derrière ses émotions
désagréables que vous ressentez quand
vous vivez une émotion désagréable et
que ce soit au travail ou à la maison
c'est qu'un de vos besoins et contrarié
là où toute la question que se pose
c'est de savoir quel est ce besoin qui
est contrarié rédiger leur rapport
annuel
ça contre 1 clairement mon besoin de
créativité devoir rentrer dans les
petites cases ça me c'est pas possible
et vous quand vous êtes agacé quand vous
avez des interactions de votre patron
quel est le besoin qui est titillé quel
est le besoin qui est contraint est ce
que c'est un besoin de reconnaissance ou
un besoin de justice quand vous rentrez
frustré deux journées de travail
quel est le besoin qui est caché
derrière est ce que vous auriez envie et
besoin de pouvoir plus vous investir
identifier ses besoins qui sont cachés
derrière vos émotions et posez vous la
question comment est ce que je peux
prendre soin de ses besoins cette
semaine au travail prendre soin de vos
besoins
c'est créer des émotions positives s'est
rajouté du plaisir
la deuxième chose que vous puissiez
faire avec ces activités qui vous
apporte peu de plaisir ou de manière
plus générale ce qui est intéressant
c'est d'identifier dans votre répertoire
d'activité les activités qui vous
procure du plaisir et simplement fait en
plus prenez en conscience et demandez à
votre but de pouvoir faire plus
activités de ce type là prendre le temps
de savourer les émotions positives
ensemble au travail
est ce que ça vous parle de ça
est ce que vous prenez le temps de vous
arrêter et de fêter la fin des projets
gratifier de vous féliciter après avoir
accompli une tâche ingrate vives et des
émotions positives
arrêtez-vous et savourer l'est et
partagez les avec vos collègues
ensuite une voie royale pour rajouter du
plaisir au travail ce sont les relations
sociales partagées nourrissait les
relations que ce soit avec vos beaux vos
collègues avec vos clients ou à y voit
fournisseurs un moyen très simple de
nour et les relations sociales c'est par
exemple de demander aux personnes que
vous côtoyez quelles sont leurs passions
de leur faire parler de leur passion et
de partager les vôtres
proposez votre soutien et votre support
en plus de procurer du plaisir vous
allez augmenter la probabilité non
recevoir pour vous même la prochaine
fois ensuite intéressez vous à ces
activités qui mobilisent peu vos atouts
ou vos compétences distribuer des
dépliants pour faire la promotion d'une
formation dans toute ma boîte
j'en suis capable mais j'ai pas
l'impression que ça mobilise mes
compétences
j'ai pas l'impression que je donne le
meilleur de moi quand je fais ça par
contre créé une capsule vidéo
humoristique virale pour faire le tour
de mon entreprise et pour annoncer cette
formation ça m'éclate
ça ça mobilise certaines de mes
compétences et certaines de mes forces
ok mon patron ne me demande pas d'aller
jusque là mais j'en suis capable
et ça m'éclate alors pourquoi ne pas le
faire si ça me prend en même temps et
vous quels sont vos forces
est ce que vous les connaissez si vous
n'êtes pas en mesure de répondre à cette
question je vous propose d'aller faire
un tour dans les questionnaires qui ont
été créés dans le champ de la
psychologie positive
je pense que vous y trouverez des
réponses intéressantes identifiez vos
forces et réfléchissent et de quelle
manière
vous pouvez plus les utiliser dans votre
travail quelles sont vos passions
quelles sont vos passions et comment
pouvez-vous éventuellement les intégrer
dans votre job vous êtes photographe
amateur pourquoi ne pas proposer vos
services pour créer le visuel du
prochain événement pourquoi ne pas
proposer certaines de vos créations pour
embellir l'espace de travail
vous avez un goût pour l'écriture
pourquoi ne pas rejoindre l'équipe du
journal d'entreprise
pourquoi ne pas vous faire plaisir au
travail en mobilisant vos forces
exploiter vos atouts
c'est aussi vous fixez régulièrement
vous même des objectifs et vous mettre
au défi augmenter votre niveau de
challenge c'est vous assurer de rester
en mouvement et de garder le frisson
pour ce job et enfin une dernière chose
que vous puissiez faire pour mieux
exploiter vos atouts c'est de continuer
à les développer et vous qu'êtes vous en
train d'apprendre en ce moment
quel est le livre qui trouve sur votre
livre de votre table de chevet continuer
à apprendre c'est élargir le panel de
compétences dont vous pourrez éprouver
du plaisir à utiliser dans votre
quotidien professionnel
en résumé et je pense que vous l'aurez
compris ce que je vous propose de faire
c'est de remplir votre quotidien
professionnel d'un maximum d'activités
qui sont pour vous source de sens de
plaisir et qui mobilise vos atouts et si
malgré tous vos efforts pour amener vos
activités vers l'intersection de ces
trois cercles vous n'y parvenez pas
posez vous la question suivante est ce
que vous êtes au bon endroit
est ce que les conditions de travail qui
sont les vôtres vous permettent de vous
épanouir au travail si la réponse est
non peut-être qu'ils étendent osé sortir
de votre zone de confort qui finalement
n'est plus si confortable que ça
peut-être qu'il est temps d'envisager un
ailleurs à vous de réfléchir
la seule chose que je vous proposais de
retenir de tout ce que je vous ai dit
aujourd'hui si on a une que vous deviez
retenir et de remplir votre agenda
professionnel d'un maximum d'activités
spa sens plaisir à tous je vous remercie
pour votre attention et soyez heureux
dans votre job au revoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]